a sex offender with a second chance is
in trouble once again thank you for
joining us at four i'm kirstjen joyce
and i'm christian casa as it turns out
when he got in trouble the first time he
was a metro police officer only our
camera was there today as a judge set
bail at one million dollars the 8 news
now i-team's vanessa murphy has more
from the regional justice center
downtown
the judge acknowledging there is video
evidence of the already convicted sex
offender committing sex crimes against
young children the details graphic and
disturbing he's facing as it stands
two counts of 35 to life
one of which is on video both of which
he's admitted to damian amalfitano
victimized a child as young as two years
old according to prosecutor jake valani
the oldest just six to seven years old
and this isn't amalfitano's first time
as an accused child predator extreme
danger to our community i wouldn't want
him near anybody in 2007 amalfitano was
accused of molesting a 13-year-old girl
investigators say they also found sexual
images of children on his computer that
was while he was a metro police officer
with six years at the department he was
immediately relieved of duty the
victim's father spoke with 8 news now
molest her
on several
several times
kept the relationship with her
amalfitano was placed on probation he
violated it went to prison and was
released in 2015. the latest allegations
while the 47-year-old man is on the sex
offender registry he is a substantial
flight risk
he has nothing keeping him here except a
life sentence if convicted las vegas
justice court judge dianna sullivan set
his bail at one million dollars
wednesday pointing out while amalfitano
has a job he likely doesn't have enough
money to post bond that is primarily to
protect the community the next court
date is set for september 19th reporting
from the regional justice center vanessa
murphy 8 news now